rtl ist es bestehe nicht einfach
bestimmen dschungel ja ist so das ist
irgendwie studio erwischte greenscreen
greenscreen ich wünsche ihm zutrauen
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft exit auf dem host server
immer noch aus regnet immer noch es
regnet immer noch zusammen mit max was
geht und über was quatsch mal denn heute
wirst du schon was angefangen du musst
das große rätsel auflösen was fängt mit
der an ist auch scheiße und dort auf rtl
er gibt viele sachen bestimmt die mit
die anfang an dsds dschungelcamp
dschungel camp okay das okay und zwar
wie guck ich das jetzt nicht so viel gar
nicht wir haben uns allerdings ein wenig
informiert und auch da ein paar kniffe
gefunden die nicht so ganz mit rechten
dingen zugeht und der max und ich werden
dann einfach darüber quatsch und am ende
euch noch etwas witziges sagen was
werden wir auch entdeckt haben mit dem
max hat das entdeckt ja genau
im fernsehen konkreter und kran crafter
klären auf dschungelcamp dürftet ihr
bestimmt erkennen läuft auch auf rtl ist
auch kacke genauso wie die erste ist
also ich selbst guckt es genauso wenig
wie luca und es ist einfach eigentlich
wirklich dasselbe ich habe nämlich wie
luca gerade eben schon gesagt gesagt hat
ich habe ich mal gegoogelt dschungelcamp
wahrheit super schlagwörter aber ihr
könnt sie auch mal bei google eingeben
da findet man einiges raus was man so
auf jeden fall nicht weiß geht einfach
junge camp wahrheit anja hier ist ein
bild faden im camp teil im echten
dschungel sind in so in solchen teichs
so gut wie immer in solchen tag
schlampig nicht in solchen teilchen in
solchen tages wird es heißt sie hätten
wir es nicht
google war der teich 2 theiss zwei
teiche leute wie du findest du dich am
teig eingefüllt
2x märkten weitergeht für komisch aus
der flure teiche scheiße
okay da steht halt in baden im camp teil
im echten dschungel sind das meist
hochgiftige schlamm das heißt man sieht
ja immer wie sie da so auf ganz ekelig
tun und so was und dann morgens in die
seen oder was auch immer daran jumpen
und in wirklichkeit würden die leute
einfach verrecken wenn in springe ich
einfach ein riesen eigentlich viel zu
gefährlich in die saison sein
seht ich keine ahnung wie es daher
dargestellt wie das die sich da im teich
baden morgens sondern baden auch mit
ihrer mit ihrer seif und alles mögliche
und über keine ahnung das werde ich auch
voll die verschmutzung der umwelt dies
darf beim baden sind wir auch wieder bei
rtl dass sie einfach die leute halbnackt
im fernseher zeigen aber dass 10
und das ist wirklich so wiesbaden wird
halt einfach gar nicht gehen steht hier
das ist von so einer bio studentin und
welche tracks wert halbiert und hört
selbst im urwald gelebt und studiert im
urwald gelebt kaka um gespielt und die
hat selbst im urwald gelebt und die
kennt sich halt wirklich aus und die
bringt erhalten perfekt in diesem
artikel die nicht ab was einfach nicht
stimmen kann am dschungelcamp und dieses
bahn ist halt einfach eins davon weil
die leute einfach an den bakterien sich
irgendwie dienstpistolen und die minis
abpacken im wahrsten sinn des wortes
spaß die eltern ja und das ist einfach
da sind sieben dschungel fehler die kann
ich jetzt mal alle vorlesen also die
einfach nicht so wirklich sagen wir
unterhalten uns halt immer noch kurz war
jeden einzelnen sehr genossen und zwar
im rtl camp gibt es schatzsuchen in
diesem komplett unbekannte junge
menschen davor nie jemand gesehen hat wo
die dschungelcamper alleine im wald
herum sprechen so im echten leben wird
man sich wahrscheinlich steht hier wird
man sich im dschungel nach ungefähr zehn
schritten komplett verlaufen weil für
leute ohne führer hier aus unserer
kultur ist es einfach unmöglich sich im
dschungel zurechtzufinden und die leute
werden einfach komplett verloren die
würden nicht zurück finden und die
ganzen kamerateams sind ja auch noch
ruft unauffällig dabei kannst du auf
hinterlegen die machen da so auch voll
verloren aber steht halt immer noch ein
kamerateam lemgo oder so rumlaufen
würden oder so dann okay aber es stimmt
dass wir dann besser trotzdem so dass es
irgendwie weiß nicht keine ahnung das
ist wenn ich hab auch bei facebook
letztens so ein foto gesehen und da
steht irgendwie so gedenkt das bett ist
immer noch jemand dabei die kamera
training möglich wird und ja weil es
wird ja alles gefilmt das heißt es ist
immer jemand da die leute sind nie
wirklich alleine und hilflos was weiß
ich ob ich könnte rtl was zutrauen dass
sie wieder verrecken lassen können
ich könnte mir vorstellen
so also hier steht mal wieder im rtl
camp schlafen und düsen ohne schutz also
unter freien himmel und die legen doch
immer ums lagerfeuer und ja sowohl aber
wahr
und dann steht da von dieser expertin
man sollte im dschungel nur unter einem
moskitonetz schlafen das den gesamten
körper umfasst weil man ansonsten
einfach verrenken würde altern kann hat
stich als ob ja doch alter das ist hier
richtig richtig wie heißt es noch
active konan like alter was ich hier
gerade herausfinde die hier stehen die
tänzerin konnten war damals immer meine
lieblingsserie ja man sieht effektiv
comment beste alter viel schlauer als
die ganzen typen und die meisten immer
so war er war so schlecht aber detective
conan ist der einzigste sabato also hier
steht der wahre grund dafür dass die
leute nicht unter moskitonetz zu
schlafen ist also beim joggen kommt ist
dass sie das rtl über das areal ein
riesiges netz spannen lassen hat als ob
das steht hier um spaß
das ist ja so heftig jünger als ob die
den versorgern heftiges netz sogar
gemacht haben wollte ich gucke nochmal
dschungelcamp netz das ist den vorstoß
dies im dschungel alter allem einem also
trauen die sich im dschungel blabla ohne
dass er nichts ich werde sogar die
insekten sind einfach nur weiß nicht
sind nicht mehr insekten und spaß das
ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie komisch
oder so hast du auf kredite mit wasser
auf jeden fall da steht einfach dass das
ein netz darüber gezogen würde falls
moskitos wurden irgendwie entfernt mit
irgendwelchen pestiziden oder so und
dann haben die nets darüber gezogen dass
die einfach da so auf und wir schlafen
unter freiem himmel ohne dass die leute
wirklich irgendwie schaden nehmen
schaden nehmen sagte ja was ist also
wenn die da gestochen werden und dann
keine ahnung wie jedes jahr - am spiel
freuen wenn sie fünf herzen damage
kriegen ja auf jeden fall das holz
genommen aber das sollte nicht weiter
stimmt seine machen gerade in hero ich
hab ich auch schon das feld genommen
oh ja ich bin daran bauen aber als man
sich das da oben besser ausfahrt man
ganz kurz die zuschauer
obwohl ich sie gleich wieder selbst
beschließen werde
habe ich von dem da oben eigentlich noch
viel
ach ja da mach ich das alles jetzt aus
diesem holz
ich habe schon wieder den nächsten fakt
den das dschungelcamp bist du bereit
ja klar also das ist auch unrealistisch
oder in wirklichkeit unmöglich dass das
die dschungelcamp menschen in weßling
also in diesen kanal die die die frauen
da immer noch diese ballerinas oder so
durch das gehölz dadurch laufen weil im
dschungel sind hier natürlich viele
bakterien medien und die leute würden
sich die füße auch schneiden an diesen
ganzen was weiß ich was dafür pflanzen
wachsen
und dann will sie sich wieder
irgendwelche infektionen holen und das
wird natürlich rtl ich passen weil die
dann jemanden rausholen müssten
blablabla das muss man sich auch mal
geben die machen da keine ahnung wie
viele wochen bei ekligsten bedingungen
und und haben einfach keine krankheiten
ja das passt irgendwie auch nicht
zusammen mit ihnen wahrscheinlich
irgendwie medizinisch behandelt oder so
vom doktor bob und wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich ist echt so dass die
einfach versorgt werden und das
heftigste ist ja man muss hier geben
es wurde mal so ein vertrag vom
dschungelcamp veröffentlicht haben
die haben einfach eine schweige klausel
da drin gemütlichen zustande da oder wie
ja ja genau wo und wie es halt wirklich
ist die müssen risiko hohe summen zahlen
falls sie denn verraten würden was was
was wirklich läuft im dschungelcamp das
heißt niemand kann wirklich darüber
reden weil die leute einfach erkaufen
kann auch niemand wirklich hinfliegen da
eigentlich das stimmt ja dass das
sowieso nie und also es ist wirklich rtl
das ist bestätigt auch bestimmt nicht
mehr dschungel ja ist so das ist im
studio richterin scream
green screen ich würde den zutrauen und
spritzig witzig witze erzählt auch recht
zu trauen
wir machen sie jetzt zu zwei rtl hält
folgen aber sie uns einfach verdient
machen es ist einfach so jeder hasst rtl
dazu gehabt und wenn irgendwer schreibt
der rtl markt dann schreibt das jetzt
mal dann blockiere ich euch ja fessel
eben gut was da steht ja sonst so hier
steht würgeschlangen dienen zur zierde
das heißt wenn er irgendwelche menschen
mit solchen bürger schlange um den hals
herum laufen das ist einfach komplett
unrealistisch weil diese diese
würgeschlange dort haben sind einfach
gezähmt das heißt die bringt gezähmte
schlangen hin die die menschen nichts
antun
und hier steht im echten dschungel
sollte man sich vor allem vor
giftschlangen in acht halten weil der
die mega schnell als sind und so was
inhalt alle menschen keine ahnung auch
ernsthaft verletzen können mit
irgendwelchen wissen und diese wirklich
einfach gezählt die den leuten da geben
und die die chill dann einfach für mit
denen und werden einfach nicht erwürgt
und sonst was
und das ist auch komplett gestellt ist
es einfach frech ja das muss man in
anderen ost gibt's da kann ich jetzt
einfach makaber und maca was vielleicht
falsch aber noch cara ist einfach nur
scheiße behindert quoten süchtig das ist
einfach nur weiß nicht und trotzdem
guckt sich jeder an auch wenn so gefragt
ist weil auch einfach ist es nicht das
ist das einzige was ich jetzt aus dieser
staffel dschungelcamp mitbekommen habe
und zwar ganz kurz meint action pack
aber und zwar das einfach eine person
ist irgendwie dabei die ist irgendwie
mal schauspielerin gewesen oder so
theater spielerin in new york und ich
mache das ganze jetzt mal hier mit einem
etwas weniger pixel liegen texture pack
ich weiß nicht vielleicht findet ihr das
cola ich finde das cool
die war
irgendwie theater spielerin blabla und
die hat jetzt im dschungelcamp immer so
schoss abgezogen piste auf die chloride
auf den randalierern klo haben wieder
seine sache so okay aber ich weiß nicht
ich hab das einfach gar nicht wie viel
dann noch schauer ist wie viel da
wirklich so vorher schon gescriptet wird
so von wegen
du machst diese folge dienst du machst
das weil es kann ja nicht sein dass die
richter alles ohne köpfe kriegen weil
wir eigentlich so drin bist dann machst
das heißt du magst die leute also du
findest nicht mit denen ab und nicht
dass es daran dass er auch schon mal
richtige dass sich durchgeboxt haben und
alles möglich und keine ahnung wenn
damit dieser irre story schreiben kann
könnte es wirklich heftig heldische
erstens ist jung camps einfach eine show
für schlagzeilen kein wunder dass
während des dschungelcamps die bild
immer also so gut wie immer irgendeinen
scheiß vom dschungelcamp auf der
titelseite stehen hat das ist echt
heftig und hier steht mal wieder was
fehler 25 im dschungelcamp kaum tiere
also höchstens mal ein zwei kleine
mücken oder mäuse oder so was halt und
diese ja diese bio studentin die
wirklich im dschungel war schreibt sie
haben jeden tag tiere gesehen also und
zum beispiel riesige gorillas oder wilde
bienen schwärmen oder sogar ratten die
so groß wie hunden gewinnt das heißt in
der echten natur sieht man einfach
riesig große tiere dir dir einfach total
gefährlich sind und dschungelcamp sieht
man einfach nur so wenig gefährliche 4
das dann irgendwelche diese dem die
weiber die die prinzessin spielen auf um
herrgott ist das eklig machen können
sowas nenne ich traue ihm auch
eigentlich wenn doch dann mitten im
dschungel auf einer solch riesiges zelt
aufgebaut wird und die ganzen
kamerateams da sind und alles mögliche
als ob da nicht einfach mal was passiert
werberings sports nennen ich verstehe
das nicht da sind doch so viele tiere
auch unterwegs die jetzt halt mega
gefährlich sind als ob da nicht einfach
mal was passiert das kann nicht sein und
spaß gibt euch ein paar per grills tag
nicht erfüllt
das ist echt geil der macht ja auch egal
ist auch komischerweise ja hier heftigen
tiere ja der trinkt dann auch einfach
mal piste war da nichts anderes hat vier
jahren gespart und nicht so wird
windiger rtl laufen würde würden sie
wahrscheinlich wie fanta einschnitten
oder so er in schwarz und und es wird
sich einfach keiner angucken weil weil
einfach keine story schreiben würde
könnte darüber dass einfach wieder
braucht er denn solange dieses verdammte
texture pack zu ändern man ich warte
schon eine halbe minute der sind als in
der noch verletzt sind oder und zwar ist
diese hier steht fröhliche pflanzerei
beim baden ist genauso wenig möglich
weil es einfach in diesen ganzen
schlammbecken mega anstrengend bis
durchzugehen und weil man saugt am boden
fest und sowas und die
infektionsgefahren wir schon relativ am
anfang und es ist einfach mega
gefährlich da und und auch wirklich
nicht entspannend in diesen segen dazu
geben und sie planschen ein warum und
man sich gegenseitig lassen müssen wir
uns dass dieser ganze stress einfach
alles gestellt und einfach diese sieben
sachen das ist so heftig fehler 7 dass
keine waffen erlaubt sind rtl fehlt
nämlich die kandidaten vor dem vor dem
jagdhund ist das ein casting ich weiß
nicht bevor die halt auf jeden fall
dahin geführt werden und der diese
experten sagt dass man im dschungel
waffen braucht damit man überleben kann
und halter ging große tiere ja naja also
um halt groß tiere verjagen zu können
und ja man muss sich halt irgendwie ja
so zurecht finden sofern das man sich
halt irgendwie etwas baut oder sowas im
dschungel aber da ist ja sowieso alles
vorgebaut und große tiere gibt es auch
nicht von der woche auch keine waffen
das ist echt heftig sodass waren jetzt
die sieben fakten und das ist einfach
wie ich sagen der beste beweis dafür das
dschungelcamp gestellt ist und einfach
nur auf geld aus
ja einfach
kommerzielle scheiße das ist einfach ich
verstehe so was nicht das ist einfach
wahr was ist echt unmöglich sich genauso
wie du ihr könnt ja gern mein kommentar
da lassen was ihr mann findet ihr
dschungelcamp genau so kacke wie wir
also dass einfach alles gestellt ist
oder findet ihr das vielleicht sogar
cool und sagte der wegen der
unterhaltung oder so geht das klar also
dass wir unsere punkte kennt jetzt auf
jeden fall
oder seid ihr eine komplett andere
meinung das segment öl das interessiert
mich gar nicht einfach komplett auch
mann und ich weiß nicht wie ich diesen
zaun bauen sind dass sie gegen ein
bisschen kaka aus dieser balkon fürs
fernsehen da kann ich dir helfen ich bin
da vinci auch an du bist einfach alles
was einfach alle alle auf einmal alle
künstler eine sache die die man auch
sagen können weil sein kann bei diesen
ganzen teilnehmern im dschungelcamp ist
ja irgendwie so so jeder
bevölkerungsschicht vertreten also sind
irgendwelche aziz dabei also so
20-jährige style november wieder mit dem
jungen sind und so auf zecken machen
dann sind irgendwelche 60 60 jährigen
schlager stars oder sowas oder
schauspieler dabei und das ist das ist
wieder beweis dafür dass einfach dass
das hauptziel wieder gewinnen ist weil
die einfach alle leute ansprechen wollen
mit der show und einfach dadurch dass
für jeden jemand interessantes drin ist
wollen sie einfach wieder erreichen dass
möglichst viele leute zu schauen und
dann zum mitfiebern oder so und dann am
besten noch für die leute anrufen dass
sie noch irgendwas zu essen kriegen
personen oder halt einfach auch damit
einfach rtl will dass konflikte
entstehen weil wenn so viele
verschiedene gruppen aufeinandertreffen
ist es quasi nicht mehr zu verhindern
dass der konflikt entstehen und dann
haben wir wieder ihre story also ich
weiß auch nicht was ich davon halten
soll er sich finster scheiße und spaß
dschungelcamp ist dass das ist genauso
wie rtl für mich für die auch genauso
wie rtl oder genau wie die ist er dafür
genauso wie die erste
natürlich
alles genauso wie dschungelcamp einfach
genauso ich weiß nicht wie ich mein haus
bauen soll nicht wundern wenn sich
einfach von denselben von dem regisseur
ist ja ebenfalls gibt es ist doch super
ist also das ist einfach alles gestellt
und so haben wir jetzt die folge wir
haben die räume komplett voll ich hab
noch eine minute
ich weiß gerade nicht ich habe überlegt
ob ich das aus diesem holz in bayern
seien diese reste auch scheiße aus aber
sonst wie ich den ball kommt ganz cool
jetzt muss ich mir nur noch dann
irgendwie einen platz finden wo ich den
weg nach oben
die nächste folge werde ich schon mal
sagen wird damit geht doch sein
ja wo kann ich dir nach oben laufenden
recht als dass hier mit cross wir
lästern über diesen kran kraft jetzt
auch total einfach kommerz das ist
einfach heftig okay da weiß der den
tisch der steht auch alles ich habe auch
gehört dass der rente die nur so rum
schreit und soja und der hec auch nur
gegen die bild damit die bild ihn mal
erwähnt und so will er halten um hetzen
ist und sondern habe ja und was ist so
ein richtiger wie hieß der noch früher
der hier auf youtube um gerettet hat
hier dieser in mainz zu dieser eine typ
der da der heftig gerettet hat auf
youtube julians glock nachher die mal in
der minecraft szene gerettet hat eine
minecraft zähne
ja es gab doch denen die einfach jeden
beleidigt hat in der minecraft szene
ich weiß die meinte der verkleinern ja
ja ja in der zeit einfach jeden gehärtet
für aufmerksamkeit
darum finde ich weiß nicht mehr wieder
heißt ich will auch wenn ich es wüsste
würde ich glaube ich jetzt nicht sagen
weil ich die stolzen wert da ist mir
eigentlich nicht besser als die leute
selbst die helfen wenn man dann die
namen sagt heiss wie rtl ja ich habe
jetzt auch er hat übrigens wieder
reserven rtl crafter ich weiß jetzt auch
wieder den namen ich sag's dir gleich
mal ja ja gut
meine damen und herren wenn es euch
gefallen hat wenn wir so über solche
themen reden gibt dem herd und sonst
schreibt uns wir halt schon vorhin
gesagt eure meinung einfach unten rein
max es auch unten verlinkt und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder
typisch